♪♪
-Folks, Earth is the most
beautiful planet
in the universe.
It's got everything you could
ever want --
Skyscrapers, golf courses,
monster trucks, you name it.
We even have cable.
But I got some bad news.
Through no fault of my own,
Earth is dying.
Personally,
I blame the immigrants.
But don't worry, because I'm not
gonna let it happen.
I'm doing everything I can think
of to save this planet.
[ Sloop! ]
-Sir, the planet
is about to self-destruct.
-Okay, plan B --
Let's get the hell out of here.
[ Zip! ]
-With that,
President Trump gathered up
all his favorite family members
and loaded them onto the finest
space force rocket 4 billion
IOUs could buy.
Then, with one last look
at the planet they loved...
-What a dump!
-...they took off
for the one place
they knew things
would be better -- Mars!
It was a long trip to Mars,
and Donald and his family
passed the time
imagining all the wondrous
things they might find.
-I bet every Mars chick
has three boobs!
-Yeah, and two butts.
-I just hope
there's a Neiman Marcus.
-I'm looking forward
to dining at Taco Bell.
-That reminds me --
Did anyone remember to pack
the cyanide pills?
[ Squeaking ]
Noooooooo!
-But since it was space,
no one could hear her scream.
Soon, the Trump family
reached Mars
and was welcomed by
the Martian president himself.
-Greetings! Welcome to Mar--
-I'm the president now.
Where's the pool?
-Pool? There's no pool.
We don't even have liquid water.
-Great. I hate water.
I'll have a Diet Coke.
-While the Martian president
searched for Diet Coke,
The Trumps set out to explore
their new planet.
-This is mine. This is mine.
This is mine.
These are mine.
-Can I see your third boob?
-And your second butt?
-Where's the mall?
I was promised a mall.
-Liquor? Booze? Do you know
where to get alcohol?
-[ Whimpers ]
-This place is almost as bad
as Earth,
but I know what Mars needs
to get back on track --
a brand-new Trump Tower.
-While Donald began demolishing
the Martian homes
in the way of his new building,
the rest of the family went out
to make their own impact
on the community.
Ivanka met with
Martian schoolchildren
and soon had them fully employed
making handbags.
-Faster! Faster! Faster!
This is for your own good!
-Meanwhile, Eric and Don Jr.
were eager to check out
the local wildlife.
-Eric, look!
It's a majestic Martian beast!
-Whoa!
-Let's kill it!
[ Zap! Zap! Zap! ]
[ Click! Click! Click! ]
-Back at the construction site,
an angry Martian mob had formed.
-Oh, thank God.
Do you have my Diet Coke?
-We don't have any Diet Coke,
and we don't have any room
for Earthlings like you.
Mars is full!
Round 'em up!
-Go! Go! Go! Go! Go!
-Before long, the Trumps
did what they do best --
they wore out their welcome.
The Martians rose up,
and together,
they chased the family
back to their ship
and off of their planet.
Sadly, not everyone made it
on board.
-Oh, no. They're going to
leave without me.
What a terrible thing that
I am not at all happy about.
-As their ship zoomed away
from the red planet,
the Trumps looked toward
a bright future.
-What will we do now, Daddy?
Where will we go next?
-Somewhere even better.
That beautiful gorgeous planet
made entirely of gold.
♪♪
And now it's time
for "Donald J. Trump
Saves the Planet."
[ Feedback ]
I, President Donald J. Trump,
am the best thing
that ever happened
to our beautiful Mother Earth.
I never get credit,
but before I came along,
she was just a 6.5.
Now she's a solid 10.
And that's all thanks to me.
So here are just
some of the ways
I'm helping to save the planet.
First, I saved us
by pulling out
of that disastrous
Paris Climate Agreement.
Nothing good
is ever named Paris,
except for that Hilton kid.
So, let's just say it was
a Paris Climate Disagreement.
I fought those Greenpeace
environmental losers and won
so I could open up more land
to fracking
for oil and natural gas.
Fracking is cool because
it's the only swear word
that Mike Pence
lets me say out loud.
[ Truck horn blows ]
Frack you, "New York Times."
[ Feedback, note plays ]
The climate is supposed
to change.
That's why they call it climate
change!
[ Dramatic music plays ]
There's only one person
who made that possible -- Me.
So vote Trump in 2020
because we don't want
the climate staying the same.
#MAGA.
I'm the only president
who understands
that hurricanes and floods
are necessary
because they keep the paper
towel manufacturers in business
to clean everything up.
Jobs, jobs, jobs.
I brought coal back
because more coal means that
trains will travel even faster,
like in that Denzel Washington
movie "Unstoppable,"
which is what the economy
will be --
unstoppable, like Denzel.
I put oil and coal lobbyists
in charge of several
cabinet positions
because government force
clean air and water onto us.
I thought Democrats were against
harassment. Guess not.
And that is just a few of
the ways your favorite president
is making the Earth a better
place.
Be sure to donate to my campaign
so we can put the money to good
use -- Electric golf carts.
[ Fanfare plays ]
[ Party horn blows ]
-[ Coughs ]
-[ Claps ]
[ Indistinct conversations ]
♪♪
-And now it's time for
"Donald J. Trump
and the Big Beautiful Wall."
There once was a President
named Donald J. Trump.
Donald loved to build things,
like skyscrapers
and an angry fan base.
But the one thing
he never got to build
was a big, beautiful wall.
The country said it was
a bad idea that wasted money,
and that made Donald mad.
So that night before bed,
he kneeled and prayed.
-Dear Colonel Sanders,
I wish for the biggest,
most beautiful wall
for my border.
-The next morning, he woke up
and turned on Fox News,
and here it was --
a brand-new wall on the border.
Donald flew on Air Force One
to meet it,
and when he got there,
he couldn't believe his eyes.
The wall was 20 feet high,
hundreds of miles long,
steel, but concrete,
solid, but slats.
Donald hugged the wall
and exclaimed...
-Hello, my big, beautiful wall.
Will you be my best friend?
-Of course!
-...said the wall.
-We will be best friends
and go on many adventures!
Hop on!
-So Donald jumped on the wall's
back and off they flew.
-Let's go fight
the Great Wall of China.
-...said Trump.
The wall laughed.
-[ Laughs ]
I can't go there.
I have to fight crime
here in America.
I have a better idea.
-...said the wall
as it turned on its side
and dipped down into
the Rio Grande River.
-I could be the world's biggest
waterslide!
-Wee!
-...Donald exclaimed as he
slid down into the water.
-Oh, no.
Oh, I forgot I can't swim.
Help me, wall.
-...shouted Donald.
But the wall couldn't help him
and flew away.
-Sorry, Donald.
I'm off to stop refugee children
from crossing the border!
-As Donald flailed in the water,
he woke up
flailing in bed.
Was it all a dream?
Donald quickly turned on
Fox News
and saw that there was no
big, beautiful wall.
Sad!
So Donald took
an executive time nap
so he could once more
go on adventures
with his best friend, the wall,
in his dreams.
♪♪